[Music]
chilling Adventures of Sabrina has
finally been released so Netflix the
ending of its first season totally
changes the character and leaves a lot
of questions and potential story arcs
for a second season throughout this
video I'll be discussing the ending of
chilling Adventures of Sabrina as well
as what I think could happen down the
road there will be heavy spoilers and it
may be worth skipping this video for now
if you're yet to watch the show without
the way I'm definition and I ruin the
show
so you don't have to buy the ending of
chilling Adventures of Sabrina the
titular character seems to be a complete
polar opposite of how she was during the
season after miss Waddell tricked the
teen into signing her name in Satan's
book Sabrina was forced to choose
between her mortal and magical side this
was in order to save Greendale however
the sacrifice that she made to came at
high cost
when Sabrina released the Hellfire to
turn the red angel of death and thirteen
witches to ash she also gained the
foresight that keeping her mortal side
would put the one she loved in danger
whilst her friends and harpy are now
accepting of the fact that she is a
witch it doesn't exactly make things any
easier for so she chooses to leave that
life behind and decides that in order to
keep them safe she must lose one of the
things that makes her personality the
most endearing it looks unlikely that
Sabrina will return to Baxter high by
the show's close but with production
already underway for a second season
that there's no way of ruling this out
Satan too can call on the character any
time he chooses now and I would
hypothesize that the second season could
be about her arc of fully embracing the
dark side of her life before eventually
returning to the light and her friends
miss Waddell is revealed to be madam
Satan and she clearly has it out for the
girl who is thought of as having the
potential to become the queen of Hell
that's obviously gonna cause a lot of
problems and conflict between the two
and I can definitely see that being a
further proof that the show could travel
then of course there are both of
Sabrina's hands the two of them find
themselves in predicaments by the show's
closed with Hilda dating a doctor that
hides the fact he is a warlock from her
and Zelda
a high priest whose daughter she has
kidnapped each one of these will most
likely come into play in the second
season and be the reason that three
realize that other than each other there
are very few that they can actually
trust I can't wait to see them come
together as a family and there's
definitely a lot to look forward to down
the line Sabrina could embrace the dark
side but I think we all know deep down
that she will eventually turn into the
light but it has been a great first
season for reintroducing the character
to a new generation so what are your
thoughts on the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina
are you excited with the new direction
that Netflix are taking and what would
you like to see in a second season
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this then please like it and
check out my other spooky wit related
video in which I break down 2015's our
movie the witch this is a channel for
people who are heavy into horror so if
that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]